Good morning, John. Welcome back. So nice to have you back, your video is great
And you were right like on every single point.
Hank Sock: No he wasn't.
Oh, hi Hank sock.
What what
Hank Sock: He was wrong on like five major points.
Well, that's technically true, but he just got back and he hasn't made a video in a long time.
And you know I'm willing to cut him some slack
Hank Sock: Cut him some slack? He hasn't made a video in three weeks
Hank Sock: He finally does it and this is what we get you have to hold him accountable
Well Hank Sock says so, so here goes. First factually inaccurate point:
John, you have now made everyone on the internet think that I did not have a girlfriend in high school and just ask Sherry, or
Sarah, or the other Sarah, or Jenny, and all of them except one of the Sarah's will
definitely tell you that I was their boyfriend. One of the Sarah's was like, " We can't use those labels,
they're arbitrary." I think she also thought that monogamy was arbitrary.
You know, like not fooling around with other guys while she was dating me.
Second thing, Albert Einstein, while not saying many of the things that people say he said, was kind of a quotation generation machine.
He said lots of really beautiful and wonderful things like in a letter to Harry S. Truman.
He said, "I do not know what weapons World War Three will be fought with,
but World War Four will be fought with sticks and stones." He also wrote to a friend,
"Do not worry about your difficulties in mathematics, I assure you that mine are still greater."
Third, the most common internet sin is not confusing your for you're, it is not exposing yourself on Chatroulette,
and it is not as you said misquoting Einstein. The most common internet sin, of course, is taking a picture of yourself
with this camera angle because you think that people will think you're more beautiful if you have a giant head. There we go, that's good.
Fourth, I do know the six types of quarks, but I also know who Amanda Bynes is.
She's the cute funny one from "Hairspray".
And I have seen "Hairspray" like five times.
So there, and to prove to you and the world that knowledge of elementary particle physics does not exclude
knowledge of teen pop culture, I have written a short song. A one, two, three four.
And finally, fifth, I checked Amanda Bynes' Twitter, and she didn't say any of the things that you said she said. Apparently you me--oh.
Hank: Hello?
John: Amanda Bynes did tweet those things
Hank: What, huh? How did you even know what I was talking about?
John: I don't know esp. But seriously, she did write those tweets.
I mean if I was going to make up someone misquoting Albert Einstein, why would I choose Amanda Bynes?
She wrote them, and then I guess she deleted them.
Hank: That ruins my whole thing,
I was gonna be all witty and talk about how John put words
about putting words in her mouth in her mouth. And that John, you misquoted her misquoting.
But it's all gone now. Wait though, that means you embarrassed Amanda Bynes into deleting her tweets.
You jerk! The internet is so weird. Let me take this opportunity now that I know Amanda Bynes watches,
Or, more likely just saw an at reply about it. Amanda Bynes, we are sorry. We think you're lovely, big fans.
Uh, and there's nothing wrong with what you did. I mean, you misquoted Albert Einstein saying a lovely thing.
I think there is a very good chance that Albert Einstein does not care at all because he's dead. In the spirit of good-naturedness,
please leave Amanda Bynes your best wishes in the comments, and if you're feeling especially creative
please misquote John and I below. Attribute to us quotes that we have never said.
And then maybe we'll say some of them, and then you'll be right. John, I will see you on Friday. Don't forget to be awesome.